for sure inside 975 blaze it today's
hottest music bootleg cameraman the
building of course juicy was here and we
got one of the biggest rappers on hydro
it up bro you know I'm problem I'll
broke his name is Wes tomato roll up in
here can I roll up yes you can okay if
you I'm sure we won't get in trouble
with a low smoke alarms there is one
there that's a sprinkler sprinkler to go
out for the sprinkler to go up I know
that there's a I don't I see I'm not a
smoker Wiz start making some coffee put
the towel under the door get this get
this rum out of here shout out to
chiquita a daiquiri bar they should have
some drinks and shout out to their holes
and a [__] strong the drinks are a bit
strong that they gave you I don't like
whiskey I like to drink gin that's what
it is that's what it is with now I was
saying I'm smoke trees i don't but
there's a couple rappers on on the list
that i would smoke weed with what do you
smoke cigarettes no I don't smoke
anything okay good but I would smoke
weed with yourself or snoop those are
the GS new yeah that's a good too yeah
definite mom currency currency too yeah
yeah don't smoke a big Sean anyway
congrats man you won the LBT award last
night yo thanks man yeah that is Major
best new artist yo that's pretty big
deal because I remember last year I was
watching too BTW awards everybody's like
you're Wiz were you sitting up like at
home at the crib or the crizzle but this
time you know not only was i there I was
nominated and I want yes that's cool
yeah that's what it is man congrats and
album rolling papers highly anticipated
finally out man and it did great first
debut number two on the charts the
shield or really well though some units
as many as people are selling in our
first week that's what I'm selling a
week now you know and it's been out for
you know a minute it's hard to do that
and it's going to keep selling to yeah
we're happy we got support from freaking
cool individuals like you and the fans
are at an all time you know yeah you're
selling out every show the fans
crazy right crazy all about the Taylor's
man it's not even mean it's crazy to
because the last time you were in Vegas
was at the house of losers it was it was
way before the album was even you didn't
even came out with a album time again
yeah everything was selling out then yep
she's been hurt because Vegas is such a
cool town yeah you guys know what it is
I here not at the album's out I get to
really you know give him a full
experience and you know have some fun
with the people now with rolling papers
a lot of like I read a lot online a lot
of people thought that it was it was a
little more like commercial friendly
what they were used to I was that on
purpose or yeah I mean well you know for
me and just development and becoming a
um you know icon and again yeah I'm it's
all about you know just that new the
newest of new right you know I can't
keep giving people the same stuff of
what they're used to and I have new fans
that you know don't know that old stuff
right so not only am i entertaining my
whole fans but I'm taking everybody into
the future you know I'm saying that past
present and future all at one time so
it's really complicated so if you fall
off you know I don't blame you because
it's hard yeah three things going on on
once and i got you can get if you can
handle it then this is for you my
favorite song and album is rooftops yo
that's what that's my French on to that
in a race yeah oh man you know as Mac
users not your favorite song yeah yeah
when I made those to those rooftops is
like that's my choice man oh man me and
currency you guys gotta drop a second
mixtape you don't even know what's gonna
happen are you going to though oh we're
gonna do something for sure I mean
that's my brother so you know like we
can't help but rat we smoked em be
friends and eat and talk about cool
stuff in there right I so in that order
you guys will get some rapping now um of
course you have a public relationship
going on right now you stop at your baby
boo yeah Amber Rose baby boo i like that
your booski hahaha dilli your boo deli
hey what's up you guys are pretty
serious man that was it as marriage
happening or um we're not engaged like
people say I know you that you got our
name tattooed on you somewhere
yeah do I finger song I got our names on
to no maximum that's a big you know
that's a big deal I mean together
forever so assuming you guys probably
get married eventually oh that's what
people do you keep letting this be
playing in my head almost like free hey
you you are you down to freestyle nah oh
I'll signal you want me start saying and
do you think with not or is it kind of
like a if its net if it's not broken you
know don't fix it kind of thing with it
with the relationship situation oh that
mean there's nothing broke there's
nothing to fix it's all good like you
know what I'm saying everything is
everything I'm just glad that people are
having fun as much fun as we are yeah
just um just by each other's company and
we're bringing you know a lot of
positive to you know what I'm saying
just the the world by our relationship
being so public and us being so caring
and love enough only for each other
before our fans yeah cuz she has a
really big fan base right following with
people who love or respect her you know
definitely ones here happy she's going
on you know just to have those forces
collide it's a real powerful thing most
definitely of course how're you came up
doing the mixtape thing um now you're on
atlantic records you got all you got the
album number two album in the country
debut of course your tour in the world
are you are you to continue to put it
you have any mixtapes on the horizon and
go put out how many I'm really bleep I'm
really focused on the album you know
anything that people get from me um on
the side is just on the side you know I
never am going to go away completely
right you know just look out for me but
the main focus and I think you know just
the way that we promote things people
get that the main focus is the album
it's the singles it's the tour you know
I'm saying that that more important
stuff and everything off to the side the
visuals and freestyles here and there I
got my man Chevy as you write him said
you yeah you're right now finish it yeah
go go download that yeah get that red
cup music you know he's got another
project on the way called cookout which
people are really going to enjoy all of
those things are coming too so Taylor
Gang of course that's your crew yes sir
is that also that's also your label I'm
assuming on what label is not officially
called taylor gang it's not going to be
called taylor gang
I want everybody to be in taylor gang
everybody listen I got my chucks on
right now exactly that's wack